how about a Broadway musical of the
whole thing
CDs goodbye with like a good album
insert with photos yes yes I would
really like to and we'll see I'd love to
inspire we could possibly set these up
after after the season comes out
productions fan run and perform
productions of up my cement that we can
come and watch I would love to see one
and there's I think right now there's
Leslie Jordan wasn't even in that around
here at he does a Hamilton ESCA bass so
he he uh there's like four five songs
within in our little musical so yeah
have you told the audience if you guys
know Apple came to me he said to me you
have to sing in a musical either I can't
sing and they were staying at my life
but by correct me if I'm correct your
hand was singing too had a beautiful
opera singer to put the stick my board
yes yes we have yeah it's something
special I can't wait to share and your
lovely fields into the the choreography
she did all the choreography for so we
got to work we got to work together
collaborate on that so we can probably
look forward to a CD of some kind of
musical CD about stupid I love the meta
I love how you have the comic book that
I did guys which is available in 2007 is
it open now it's over next now I'll be
there and and in the spectrum if you
don't know spectrum is the show within
the show it would be like our Firefly
the show that got canceled that too soon
I love you guys spinner this question
you were all tempted to kill him that's
a great idea
I'm glad Nathan some of it no more
questions good I've got a twist Allen
Allen
yes your busy guy no my your busy guy
you've been doing voice work like crazy
you just got finished with Star Wars
rogue one yeah powerless with NBC yes
yes which is another kind of superheros
job yeah the DC it's like the DC's first
comedy it's gonna be an office company
but we're shooting in about a month
how do you do that all I can't manage
one job I can do
the important thing is PJ Haar's but I
think it's the most important one for
con man in all things but also working
with people all the people you see at
this dais here that you can trust that
they're gonna do great work that you can
just cure you know on set I hope one set
we're able to go you know it's not hard
and fast some things I don't know Ben do
you hear this sometimes no yeah do this
exactly but you know what you aren't so
open and generous with things and PJ I
mean almost starts at the top I think
they are and how they make everything so
joyous and easy and fun and so that says
a lot to how I think this whole thing is
run beautifully yeah the crash service
was also very good I ate a generous
amount of almond butter and I appreciate
the inclusion of almond butter in the
craft service because that's a rarer
butter yet it wasn't just perhaps terms
like we bumped up cop services this year
but the crew that we had all came back
from last year there's a bunch of crew
in the audience right axe is falling
there at the end that's uh engaged on
stage last yeah that was probably my
favorite thing of walking on set for
season two was seeing the same crew
because it was such a testament to how
great season one was to work on you know
where this tiny little show that crews
work on in between their big fancy shows
and they all came back there is a joy
and dedication on set is really nice
it's know what this is right whatever
all right but it's certainly become a
possibility that I can actually be an
actor this is what I hoped it would be
like being an actor is doing this kind
of stuff with friends with people with
making new friends meeting new people
and it being a joyous thing I'm not a
challenging Durga though I got a job
every day what do I get
do today yeah and and also with fans in
it like fat no way tacomas crowdfunded
and so it was made by fans it was 600
fans came back this year to be in it yes
642 fans signed up let me use them all
so like when you see cons and we've got
a couple of cons this season and there's
there's cosplayers any fans that were in
it that are here though there are some
grandmas there we go Karlis I really
appreciate the clothing optional the
clothing optional the clothing optional
that was listening : me we need you to
put your pants back I told you it was in
my contract what you might on a piece of
paper with a red crayon there's a
contract in writing crayon is legally
binding and then you directed any
episode of season 1 yes how many
episodes of season 2 did you I direct
the half of them this season because I
was because of the comic book and all of
those things and also wrote one that was
that was attempt a bit of a challenge
like I was in like letting go to have a
different director yeah you did my god
it was yeah it was it was it was it was
I'm having trouble letting go on jobs at
Armond now I'm the reshoots of road one
they said okay we're gonna get this done
I think are we ready I was like yeah
we're ready let's take all guys come on
good job sorry everybody
so yeah I'm power-hungry I do Liam you
renewed this year to the set was it like
oh it was like the best Testament I can
say is that so I wasn't there for that
many days of role but I was so sad when
I realized it was my last day I was kind
of like ready you guys want to make like
another 20 50 episodes yeah whatever
but it was so yeah it's it's so much
probably obviously the occasional punch
of the face makes it a little more
exciting yeah that's good that's ooh
that is no joke don't upset Alan Tudyk
that guy looks a little sweet innocent
happy how many roles in the United
States or basically have you been able
to use your natural accent none was it
weird like hi oh sorry oh that's right
that's my what if I have to do this
accent have to put on some crazy thing
anymore
it was I've got like fraud I'm like I'm
doing it wrong I'm sorry your American
accent is so good but I hear you're
Australian sometimes I think it's fake
it isn't and the thing is I can't use my
actual voice I have to put on some kind
of super Australian accent good night
ladies
that's not why that's me we had a lot of
fun with Australia this year that's
really good taking all the jobs because
they're just more American and like the
Hemsworth we can't figure out how many
Hemsworth there are they just there
they're like zebras they they huddled
together to hide their numbers as
Farnsworth hens were the neighbors
modern-day Baldwin's huh
the modern table modern day exactly and
so girth girth is final Hemsworth hi
Jason
thank you I do this I do this sometimes
when I'm what I'm actually working and
acting and I'm watching a scene and I
get so into it and I think about these
guys are really good and this is really
this is gonna be great on TV why is it
anybody talking right now and it's right
now having a moment and I do this
sometimes where I say this is a really
great moment
I'm gonna lock this into my memory and
just kind of I'm gonna keep this moment
I'm looking down here and I'm having a
moment you call me up I know did you
tell the best stories maybe that's why
you just you start over here Alison yes
you've swooped in last season we had a
last-minute cancellation now and
desperately for someone to come in and
rescue us that was you yeah I thought
Alan butt-dialed me I got the phone call
11 a.m. on a Saturday I'm like there's
no Alan Tudyk Scott
for any important reason right now so
season 1 took you quite by surprise what
it took you
season 1 took you that yeah well how was
it different for you in season 2 um
while getting the script more than 48
hours in advance was definitely a big
difference I know I was just really
interested to see where faith was going
to go and I got so excited to get the
scripts and when I started reading them
there were all these comments about my
eyebrows look it in and like first time
I read it I was like hilarious cuz I do
have big eyebrows and then there was
like another comment and then there was
another comment and at the end of it I
was like I was like Iceni capable of
telling you this in person and he's like
cathartic me writing it out and the
script I was like oh I've never played a
character where the physical features
are commented on because it's actually
me you know their comment on your
character's personality who cares that's
acting but it was what it's your own
physical appearance you're like I don't
have a problem we cut a couple of them
there was a waitress that I was going to
for a while who would really bought into
the eyebrow and they weren't they were
like you know into the woods there was a
lot for like those trees in The Wizard
of Oz where it was really god bless her
I'm here
she needed somebody to tell her and so
your eyebrows don't do that so I don't
know I'm just going to wear while we're
in the writers room and you took the
brunt of it
Lutheran the rules you get in my mind
I'm imagining right before you go out so
you you you pump up a little bit you
little pump go in the kind of roles that
they're gonna say hey we need that we
need a Lou Ferrigno type maybe you get a
little pump going on but in con man when
Alan said I need you to sing I mean
that's a little outside your comfort
zone you said why think it's beyond the
comfort zone because I never sang in my
life you know what sweating out I was
funny I trade Michael Jackson for years
and uh it was a client of mine so one
day Michael said to me could you sing
happy birthday so once I'm over singing
happy birthday if they let's get back to
working out but every kissing Brahm
estatic about it I was scared because I
said to myself I'm not gonna listen
ain't a master song and everything but
it's funny had a great choreographer all
this debt and articulate the words of
everything McClane experienced occurred
especially of the minds of men being
abused at home so the whole different
spheres I had a great time did you break
into a sweat because when someone asks
me to do something I've never done
before
like what oh thank you when when joss
whedon asked me to be in a musical I've
never kind of saying like that
with you because I love you so did you
ever attention it's a pirate ship where
they cuss a lot did you get nervous and
thing but maybe I shouldn't do this did
you did you for one second thing I'm not
gonna do it though I said to myself it's
a new experience and I love taking risks
of my life and it just taught with the
attitude of learning something but
before something on the static reduction
I figured that just go for it I mean
it's just like acting have a new
experience so I think about being
nervous
I'm so glad and I think I tell you one
thing how are you into bald cap we were
very free to share that switch with you
really yeah because I'm so being because
I got like three things going for me and
two of them are my hair I do detection
well it's a very funny bit you it came
from you've gotta let me on Letterman I
saw you do that that so I saw that
obviously we've all now seen it you're
not gonna unsee it you just can't
and take it a step further and the hair
of the bulb with the hair on the side if
you have that you know it's good it was
very what you saw it it's it's outside
of my comfort zone yes yes you look like
a young Peter Boyle yes I look like my
head's a Johnny boy it's like a dog I
tore the end well I remember Ellen you
you called me up to say we got live ring
him like he's gonna do it he's you were
so you wanted that musical Of Mice and
Men as soon as that that the idea came
up you wanted it so badly
yeah and you were a little concerned I
think is it gonna happen yeah and it
didn't nobody else nobody else could
have done it there's nobody else who
could have done it and made it as good
like there's it's like if blue says no
the game is rolling we wrote it without
telling you
wait were you afraid we're gonna make
him angry you know something funny when
you get to see this show they actually
get a full production used to go faster
but if you put this show on Broadway it
would have been the same and yeah it's
ready to go it's ready to go then thanks
to Alan because officially he directed
the episode anything wonderful to think
of I think and great job thank you thank
you
there was another one of those things
where look what just a little snippet of
a song a little bit of a song to
full-blown whole musical productions
with choreograph yeah comic book artists
come in and do the sets yeah painted
although yeah
we have comic book artists in the
background like
you know yeah that's a good but that is
one great thing when you get to be in
charge as you know and everybody is so
cool about it it's I think unless after
I walk away to start bad-mouthing me
like a few days I'll go I need a horse I
need a horse just a 2-dimensional horse
and cut off its legs
I got no legs on this horse and then we
had a horse and you you did the horse
yes you were the horse head it actually
was the most dangerous stunt on the
whole season too because at one point I
had think they said why don't you just
kick me and I did like I just a brush it
aside because no really kicking did it
hurt blue Ludi we all know we don't
under Louisiana go and everybody wanted
to take a picture with Lou and see him
and I had my daughter Scottie with me
backstage and she had something in her
eye and I'm trying to put drops in there
I couldn't she wouldn't stay in it and
she would drop in disappears all I see
I looked over we're like what Rams head
don't squeeze it don't squeeze it
I mean I just I had that game of Thrones
you know that guy's so hot you guys as
someone a party less you're not scolding
you're really hot did not go over well
anyway ladies and gentlemen this has
been amazing I had done some pedals in
my time that have been amazing this has
been the most amazing panel ever I think
you'll agree
I hope you guys enjoy content season 2 I
hope you enjoy the digital comic and I
certainly hope you enjoy a con man the
game August August when you fight
starving you feel the audience and watch
us on Comic Con HQ ok make sure you go
there and watch the show please
you